[Music]
the second trailer for doctor strange in
the multiverse of madness arrived just
ahead of the 2022 super bowl and holy
sorcerer supreme it was totally epic the
latest trailer sees dr strange haunted
by the events of his past as a new
threat emerges one that may involve
another doctor strange we've already met
it is up to strange and his allies to
find a way to put his own world back
together again multiverse of madness
will not only see benedict cumberbatch
reprise his role but we'll also see the
return wong and mordo as well as
christine palmer elizabeth olsen will
also join forces with doctor strange as
wanda maximoff debuting the next phase
in scarlet witch's powers as she aids
her fellow supreme being and guides him
in the ways of the multiverse amidst all
of the madness there are a handful of
small but oh so intriguing details that
tease just how complex and far-reaching
doctor strange's next adventure in the
mcu will be at about the 40-second mark
in the trailer you can see a bleak
faded-out shot of new york city
buildings dissolving into nothingness
implying that doctor strange has somehow
caused a rift that will unravel reality
this isn't the first time we've seen dr
strange's bad behavior lead to this
civilization ending type of disruption
if you saw the fourth episode of the
animated series what if you may
recognize that effect in that episode
what if doctor strange lost his heart
instead of his hands dr strange's
girlfriend christine is in the car with
him when he has the accident that in the
original movie damaged his hands dr
strange becomes a master of the mystic
arts and uses the eye of agamotto to
manipulate time he uses it to try and
save her only to find in a series of
heartbreaking vignettes that this just
isn't possible in desperately trying to
find a way to save her he becomes split
into two versions one evil and one good
they fight and create a paradox that
begins to tear reality apart the
dissolving effect in what if looks
darker and inkier than what's happening
in doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness but the dissolving of reality
has a similar feel to it and the
callback appears to result from the same
type of misdeed on doctor strange's part
we'll just have to wait to find out what
that is one of the most explosive
sequences in the new multiverse of
madness trailer depicts the titular
sorcerer being led down a corridor in
handcuffs to a massive room where
several prominent figures their faces
currently unrevealed are seated while
little is confirmed in the trailer it
has long been rumored that the movie
will introduce a multiverse flavored
version of the illuminati a shady group
that in the comics is comprised of such
major heroes as doctor strange reed
richards tony stark namor and charles
xavier whenever they want to plan some
shady happenings if the trailer is any
indication and if the illuminati rumors
prove true then it seems that the army
of ultron robots leading strange are
their personal guards and soldiers as
for who will comprise the mcu illuminati
there have long been rumors of alternate
universe versions of characters seen in
prior marvel projects and this would be
the place where they would most likely
show up the illuminati could include for
instance an alternate universe version
of tony stark though that seems unlikely
or reed richards john krasinski perhaps
as well as mordo played by chiwetel
aegeafor perhaps the most mind-blowing
inclusion though would be charles xavier
which makes it all the more intriguing
that during this scene of the trailer
there is a moment where we appear to
hear the voice of patrick stewart the
actor who previously brought the x-men
leader to life and the fox films will
the mysterious illuminati appear in the
film or are these ultron guards just
spinning us in the wrong direction for
now fans are eagerly awaiting more
information doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness looks like it will
bring more characters from marvel's vast
library into the mcu the latest trailer
features a cameo from rintra an alien
creature that was inspired by the
minotaurs of greek mythology originating
from the extra-dimensional planet reval
rintra is an intelligent being who
possesses supreme strength as well as
sorcerer abilities such as magic and
shapeshifting reintra has been an ally
to strange in the comics in the past at
one point he even served as his
apprentice though he eventually made the
leap to becoming a full-fledged sorcerer
in his own right the minotaur is also
known for his association with
anithurman the weaver a powerful and
reclusive magician who resides in an
alternate dimension if rintra is in the
hotly anticipated sequel then it's very
possible that his old mentor will make
an appearance as well
dr strange and the multiverse of madness
arrives in theaters on may 6th
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite mcu movies and shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]